I am joined by dr. Sarah Jones and
before the podcast we've been nerding
out on all of the different gadgets and
stuff that we've got floating around our
house so that is going to be the
continuation of today's episode Sarah
welcome the show thank you very much for
having me it's a pleasure to have you on
you have the world's first PhD in
immersive storytelling correct what's
that what I'm sure I won't be there I
might be the only one so very long I'm
sure there'll be lots more coming up
right behind me with regard to immersive
storytelling and I usually say it's
immersive story living as a way to kind
of define it a little bit more but
basically what I do is grab any tech
that I can and break it to find a new
way of having the story so story living
is all around that kind of immersive
experience where it's completely rooted
in the experience in the experiential so
therefore you can't really have a told
story it's not really a directed
narrative so you got to break it apart
and then you live it in whatever way you
want there forward story living so yeah
I did my PhD I got my PhD in story
living the first one but yeah it's
pretty good that's fun so what are some
of the examples of the kind of
technologies that you work with I've
always experimented with whatever I can
get my hands on really so my background
was in television journalism so I was a
reporter for like ten years
traveled all the way around the world
telling stories and I always wanted to
just get closer to those stories I
wanted to find a way of really taking
the audience and putting them in the
heart of it so I was right the start of
the mobile phone movement and mobile
fame filmmaking and
shooting and editing everything on your
phones and I found that that could get
you closer but it still wasn't close
enough because whenever you're watching
anything there's this barrier and that
barriers the screen and it's always in
the way and then when I did my first
kind of VR experience this is it now I
can take you the audience and I can plug
you in the center of the story and
you're there and you experience it then
yourself so from all kinds of things
from normal film to AR to VR to 360 film
which is obviously the easiest way to
experiment but at the moment I'm really
fascinated with Holograms and what you
can do with those and I haven't made
anything decent but I will say it's just
the case of experimenting and breaking
and trying to find how these
technologies see different mediums
that's interesting so is your are you
coming at this from a tech coding side
or are you coming at this from more of a
grand perspective what can it do
what's its of capabilities side I think
the latter and certainly more that kind
of artistic side I tried to learn how to
code probably about five six years ago I
saw okay I really need to do this
clearly I'm missing that skill so I
started learning and then I thought you
know what there's people they're
brilliant at this I don't need to kill
myself trying to do it I just need to
find those people especially if it's not
in your wheelhouse
exactly yeah some guys who eat that
stuff for breakfast
but would find would find the
storytelling that you do like just
crawling through glass so you might have
yeah I mean I I have a basic knowledge
I can understand it I know what I need
to do and but I I think what's really
interesting about working in kind of
technology for the
kind of artistic side the narrative side
the experience side is there has to be a
collaboration and that collaboration
means you need that specific group of
people to make magic and not one of
those people can do it by themselves you
need everybody there and that's what's
really exciting really because I feed
off everybody else's mind you know I
need to be stimulated by all those Minds
to make something great so it's quite
quite good in that respect but yes
certainly that kind of artistic side
looking at what can we really do with it
I think a lot of the problems and I've
been quite critical of some people for
for doing it is then you get a new
platform or new technology and you just
apply old ways of thinking to it that's
really and I think well it there was a
prime example and I always name and
shame them as an example is scary yes
they so sky knees did their first VR
experience and it was the reporter on
the migrant crisis doing a story on the
beach and they'd obviously filmed if a
live report first off as a flat flat
version for for traditional television
and then they filmed it with a 360
camera they filmed it for VR 360
capturing everything you can look around
tilt and rotate on your phone whatever
it might be they did exactly the same
thing they didn't think about what can
we do differently because we have a
spherical camera how can we tell this
story differently what does it mean from
the audience perspective of watching a
story flat having the narrative told you
or actually being there on the beach how
does that change what you do and I was
really critical of them for doing that
and then the next day they announced
that they had a new sky and VR studio
and so my timing was a great but III
hold treat that belief that it's just
really lazy and you know my background
is in journalism and it always reminds
me of when online journalism started and
it was just simply you know you get your
story
and you copy any paste and you put it
online and then you upload the video and
you don't think it's a different
audience and they're consuming it in a
different way so they needed to be
different so so I think that's really
where a lot of the mistakes are so I
trying to do is start on that blank
canvas and think what can I do that I
can only do because of this technology
so it's not really technology for
technology's sake it's more thinking we
owe it to the tech to make it great and
to break it and find new ways of using
it how would you how would you
characterize the difference between the
use of something for traditional flat
screens and that for VR if you won't if
you were designing it if you were the
lady there was at sky that day on that
beach what what how does it look
different what do you do it's about the
experience so whenever I'm planning
issues on anything it's always the first
port of call whereas in flat you would
kind of do a storyboard do you think if
you saw you middle on your end when
you're doing something for VR or 360
it's closing your eyes and thinking what
is it what's that experience so you're
trying to get somebody to experience
what is it about being in that specific
place so you need to capture and then
how can you capture it so I did
something a couple years ago in Hong
Kong in Chungking mansions which is this
crazy crazy huge international kind of
market scene it's the most insane place
in the world totally chaotic 4,000
people staying there and all these
really cheap hostels like the cheapest
place where you can stay and going in
there you know it's dark it's dingy
there's so many different smells and
noises and everything is going out going
on so for me being in that environment I
was like I need to capture that and
capturing an experience and a feeling is
really difficult to do it's not like
just telling the story like
you know all the smells are so intense
and these people are doing this you
can't do that you've got to put someone
in the heart of it so so to do that I
broke all of the kind of very early
introductory editing conventions in VR I
had a lot of moving shots because I
wanted people to feel disjointed and
uneasy I had various kind of carrying
shots here at different levels I had
lots of quick edits and to make people
feel jarred and that was how you could
capture the experience so it's all
coming down to that really instead of
what is the story that I'm trying to
tell it's what is the experience I'm
trying to create and then it's a real
shift in the mindset it's really hard to
try and think in that way it can be
easier in some ways but a lot harder in
others I suppose thinking about it the
when you are trying to capture something
for flat screen your position in terms
of camera is framing the scene as is
best appropriate whereas for VR it's
literally the point of view it's what is
the optimal point of view is that is
that the distinction between the two
yeah see and there is no frame you know
that the frame has dawn you always have
like this this frame in front of you one
on a flat screen and then suddenly
that's gone I can make something and
have 10 different people watch it in 10
completely different ways taking
different narratives from it it doesn't
always have to be that way and a lot of
people do try and direct the narrative
and use cues like lights and sounds and
and force the gaze to different places
but I tend to argue against that and
think no I want people to just
experience it and we all experience
things in different ways so let's forget
about that and put the trust in the
audience to just let them create their
own experience it might be me being lazy
it's as if you can't watch it again as
well so I got a an oculus rift actually
have an ex mrs. I got an oculus rift
I've sold it now but often ex-missus and
one of the things that I found myself
doing was watching the same sequence
multiple times because you can only see
however much is in your field of vision
and you know I actually I'll go back and
I'll have a look I'll see what happens
if I look that way very yeah where is
once you've watched it flat screen
that's it right you there's no there's
no more yeah new ones really there's a
lot less than you once at least yeah I
mean you can get back into me I remember
watching Breaking Bad and then watching
it so many times having read all the
different color cues and all those kinds
of things but that's very very different
certainly in VR you you can have
different people watch it in totally
different ways and that's really
exciting it's really hard if you're
trying to direct something and you want
the control so for control freaks it's
awful but it is really interesting just
letting go and thinking yeah people will
experience it however they want so let's
let them say say yeah I mean what's
really interesting you mentioned that
the wrist the the new oculus quest is a
game I want you after that so the oculus
quest came out I think maybe about two
months ago which is one of the first
real standalone VR headset CRT I had a
go I had a go sorry I don't oculus oh
okay so the quest is the next step up
from the go so the quest you've got two
controllers and you've got a space
around you you can play beat Sabre which
is one of the greatest games in VR we
have the beat Sabre is like remember the
90s or make maybe the naughties the
dance challenge mats in arcades where
you have to jump and and you know
your right foot and your left foot and
danced around it's like that but in VR
but you're hitting these things so so to
watch other people doing it it's a
little bit weird but you watch them and
you're just like banging two different
music words beats and it's awesome it's
an incredible exercise phase really
really cool so so highly recommend
anybody think beat saber and that's
probably one of the things that's
driving sales of oculus quest because
everyone wants to play beat saver and
now you don't need a huge laptop or PC
to run it it just runs so I think with
that and then five have their own one
coming out as well where again you don't
need to be tethered to a machine that's
all massive you know this is huge really
it might actually allow the tech to be
more accessible which is good yeah like
there has to be a good thing yeah I
think one of the things that I noticed
have seemed floating around for a while
PlayStation VR and when oculus first
came out where I think it was like you
needed an Android phone or something to
link it up to and other bits and I was
just thinking it just feels quite clunky
and it's not really that cool and then
even the oculus go I mean that said I
didn't pay for it but even the oculus
girls that I had last year I thought was
was cool and I enjoyed watching things
but what I was conscious of and I did a
little bit of reading um
can you explain to the listeners what it
happens to the resolution of a video
when you then start to wrap it in into
their headset because I instantly
noticed some of the videos I was
watching look lower quality but
apparently that was more to do with the
way that it needs to communicate it to
your eyes is that right yeh it can be so
different headsets and it'll all be
whether you download to them or whether
you are streaming them and however you
are doing it I always get questions
around you know I I want to make
something in 360 I want a 360 camera
which one should I buy and there's one
camera that I use all
time as a basic entry-level kind of
prosumer camera which is the insta 360
1x insta 360 make a great range of
cameras really really great company and
there as it now says the 1x is 5.7 K so
you think brilliant this is really good
like this is going to be great in a
headset but those five points to 7k
pixels of being yeah if you're watching
something flat it's in front of you in
that resolution we now have to put all
of those resolutions out there those
pixels all the way around us so it's the
360-degree image that's made up of all
of those pixels so it's never gonna be
as good as watching a altra HD
television flat massive screen all that
kind of thing it's just not but it is
getting better I was gonna say when that
cut now what's it progressing to I think
I think the stats when I had to go were
that if you downloaded something weren't
streaming it had it on optimal
resolution all this sort of stuff it
could get to about 720p that right 1080
on on the quest isn't bad it's it's good
we just got so spoiled with 4k and some
yeah I mean I would say that after after
a couple of minutes in it you get used
to it your eyes adjust to it and then it
all becomes normal so I lived in VR for
48 hours a couple years ago when what if
they's you know crazy things you decide
on a day after you're gonna do I had a
five minute comfort break every hour
okay cool yeah right what about one of
it was eating with ya eating in a
headset drinking has a sleeping in a
headset working in ahead sir racing car
driving in ahead sir
envy
but we'd like to look through camera
three through the head sir all those
kinds of things I did it with a
colleague of ER colleague of mine Dean
Johnson we did it together
he got a tattoo wearing a headset to
monitor the difference in heart rate
based on your where they could be pain
reducer wearing a headset which it did
his heart rate went down dramatically
when he was wearing the headset so all
those kinds of things really really
interesting but when I was doing that I
I generally don't like cartoony things
in VR I like photogrammetry I like
realism I like to feel like it's real
but we were doing a boxing thing with
this real cartoonish dude he looked like
one of the characters from The
Incredibles you know I don't believe
it's real at all but after a couple of
minutes boxing him it really felt real
and there was some things there around
the haptics like there was a vibration
as you were punching him the screen
would go black as if you like when you
got knocked as if you were like a little
bit starry-eyed and losing your vision
slightly so there were loads of things
like that the really tricked your mind
and you kind of get used to it
so yeah the resolutions not all that
great but it's getting there getting
better yeah have faith don't get me
wrong it's a hell of a lot more
immersive than watching something on a
TV that's at the end of you bed all
right or in the mounted on the wall in
the living room it's definitely a very
different sort of experience so what do
you think at the moment if you were to
put your money where your mouth was and
someone let's say someone has a VR
headset at home and they want to see the
the coolest thing or the most impressive
thing or just your favorite thing right
now why would you direct them what
should they watch and what is it and why
this is really difficult because the
couple of years I've been really bored
as a huge advocate for the technology I
have been really bored why because I've
I felt like there's there's been a lot
of pressure on people to make stuff
obviously for commercial reasons and to
find an audience and to do all that kind
of stuff
and it doesn't allow people the time to
be creative and break things a little
bit and understand the different things
that you can do and you need that time
you know it's a new tech work it's not
new technology it's been around since
third night in 1965 as a first headset
so it's been around forever
but you need time to really find the
good stuff and that's quite hard to find
so I mean there are great but beat Sabre
is a great game I really really good if
you'd like to have social vr you know
you can go into Netflix in a headset and
watch something as if you're in the
cinema and that might be to some
people's tastes I don't understand it
personally because I could just watch
Netflix on my TV but you know it can
happen so there's things like that
I like VR less so for being a home but
in a social experience and an event so
I'm a big fan of that full kind of
immersive experience there's something
on in London at the moment that's an
immersive experience of War of the
Worlds and it's a two three-hour
experience and it's an event as if
you're going to the theater there are
actors there there's sweep you around
along and take you into different places
you go through one area and then
suddenly people are throwing a rucksack
on your back a sub pack
and strapping a headset to you somewhere
else
so still available for this yeah I think
just for these new dates and it's on
until January so it's definitely worth
checking its dr. dot the the creators
and it's a proper experience it's as if
you're going to the theater if they got
anything to do with this Star Wars one
that was on named ember that one that
that was a void yes void state so the
void did Ghostbusters as well the void
are a huge company they've been bought
by Disney now but they do those big
immersive experiences and for me that's
where the technology really comes alive
because you've got it as a group and but
you can add so much to the experience by
having it in a headset so you know you
jump into a frame of a boat in real life
but then you put on a headset and then
you would be in the boat so so you've
got all these different things going on
and those various like projections and
Holograms and that kind of stuff as well
and you have an interval when you're in
this bar and all the tables changing
color and lighting up and everything
else and then you carry on with the
experience and that kind of thing is
great because you are sharing it even me
and as nerdy as I am I don't sit at home
in the evening you know what go stick on
my headset over there and you know yeah
there's something that I
I don't it's a lot of effort and I'll
say if you think about how awful a lot
of people are now we watch TV at the
same time as we might be working on our
laptop in the evening at the same time
that we might be instagramming something
else or checking someone else's social
and we do multiple things at the time at
one time in a head saying you can't do
that just
say you've got to be really in something
I'm gonna be watching someone get all
that attention yeah no but I mean
they'll ask them there's a great
experience and visage and I see all of
these are experiences that you go to
Sharla micawber did a great flight of
the future experience where you're in
this this kind of sphere kind of light
up thing and you were leaning against
something you had to flap your wings to
become a bird and learn to how to fly so
you started to fly and then it took you
on the whole journey of flight so from
the first flight up until a few flights
it was all sponsored by British Airways
and that was really interesting again so
you had these different experiences you
added in different scents you added in
heat there was wind so you had this full
kind of it and immersion on lots of
different levels and that was really
cool so there are really good things
being done but sitting at home saying or
unless watch this I must watch that it's
still quite limited yeah I think I found
like I think last year I was watching
sport like on Facebook live now yeah and
there was a part of me that thought
there's novelty to this but there was
another part of me that was thinking I
don't think this is that cool of fun
it's just a bit novel about you sure
that should I be thinking it's cooler
because everyone else thinks we are like
the future and yeah you're right it's
repurposing existing content in an
existing format and just putting it in a
worse resolution but close your eyes
yeah that's what that's what that is and
then yeah in the flip side of that the
Star Trek Star Wars void thing that I
desperately tried to get to the co-hosts
join your music to go to you we're gonna
force them to go to this war of the
worlds' things I'm gonna hold them
accountable and we'll talk about on a
future podcast that you know that sounds
really cool yeah we were a freshers
event earlier on this week and they had
one of the stalls there
I don't even know I don't think it would
have been anything tremendously
sophisticated but this brand just had a
VR headset and then I come over and you
can race a car or do whatever it is so I
think there's still so much novelty and
so few people have been exposed to the
technology that you can just put off the
shelf
probably headset pop it on someone and
be like look like this is this is how
crazy and quirky we are as a company
yeah so yeah I guess there's a lot of
low-hanging fruit for people to do that
um one of the things that I noticed
again with the oculus go was the file
size of these videos is insane
especially for the long run since the
Jurassic Park one did you see that one
yeah that was awesome that was my
favorite one terrifying it's only three
three or four minutes long with this
file size is insane and even with that
you can only mu you don't move you are
moved on a on a track through this
particular film so you can imagine that
you're walking through a jungle and
stuff happens and you can pan around
with your headset we can't control the
motion if you were to start to create
worlds that were rendered to that sort
of resolution plus were being created as
you go I'm gonna guess that's that's
technology that's not quite ready yet is
that right well I mean is if you're
tethered to a computer so if you've got
the the rift or device and certainly to
some degree you've got that on the quest
as well which is really good so you are
starting to open up those kind of
multiple worlds not infinite obviously
but different ways that you can move
around and explore different areas so
that's really happening now which is
great because that's what's needed it's
really difficult in in things but if I
work with film and I work with 360 then
you can't really do it with that it's
not really that there's
ways to add interactivity but not
freedom really of space you need to be
using kind of photogrammetry where
you're taking like millions for millions
of images of one thing and splicing it
all together squishing it all together
to create a digital image so you can
start doing that but it is moving really
quickly obviously starting back in 1965
but in now it's moving really quickly
it's weird with this stuff though right
because we were seeing in front of our
eyes how multiple areas of technology
need to be able to come together to
enable something so with this let's say
that X number of years ago we would have
had the lens capability to have been
able to show what was going on but
because of the the file size is you
actually need the storage and then
potentially if you want to have
something which you stand alone you need
a battery the battery on the Occulus
goal was terrible that there were
periods where I couldn't get the oculus
go to charge because it didn't have
enough battery to start up and it would
like what was its whole charge down just
trying to start up on charge that was
weird yeah and looking at these file
sizes we need better storage we need to
be able to make sure that that's that's
able to happen and stuff like that so
yeah it's weird how all of these you
were talking earlier on about how
everyone needs to play a role yeah I
mean now we'd like 5g and all that kind
of stuff that's going to make things
really like that will help that will
make things better and it is getting
easier I mean I remember when when I
first started filming things and having
to try and stitch it all together
manually so so I would film on real so
I've just dropped you that I'd film on
rigs of loads of GoPros and then I would
have to put it through software to
stitch each of those images together to
create one Saphira collage and now it's
most
there's lots of program so you can put
things through and it does it all for
you I still try and manually stitch
because it took me so long to learn how
to do a flawlessly bursty the algorithms
are great you know it just happens but
those are those kinds of things there
through a group working with in this
space it's getting easier I did a work
with Google on a couple of different
experiences and they gave me one of
their their Google Odyssey cameras this
jump I was one of their jump creators
and it was basically 16 GoPro rig huge
it was massive the power bank they ran
off yeah well you couldn't even carry
icon Terrier you know was not mobile
filmmaking whatsoever but it was great
and with all of that you they developed
their software that you just plugged it
all in and it went up to the cloud and
they stitched it and then they told you
any was ready the file size is meant
that it took this anywhere between five
and seven days to stitch things like
rendering for about 16 hours at a time
but it is getting so much better is
there ever gonna be a time where we're
going to see blockbuster films filmed in
full VR or do you think that the
inherent difficulty in all of the added
elements that you need to be able to
control is just going to make that and
no no no I think they will and I think
there's one feature-length be asked
owners come out and that one of the
longest films kind of that I've seen I
think is a good length was around 18
minutes I was a piece
called control ctrl which was one of the
most powerful pieces that I've seen as a
good few years ago and it was all it was
around the gaming community eSports but
there was lot lots of Darkness around I
don't want to say too much in case
anyone manages to see it because it's
really really powerful so so that's the
kind of maximum length so you get full
of experiences that kind of 18 minutes
max most around 8 to 10 4 kind of a
normal experience but but I think there
will but it might not be film as we know
it so it might not be sitting down and
watching something for you know 120
minutes it might involve more movement
or activity so that's quite different
then so yes but not as we know it and I
don't think we would go to the cinema
and then on the seat in front of us
there would be a headset that we were
going on but but I could see that
happening more in kind of theater
companies but there's part of and a lot
of theater companies have experimented
with that there's part of a production
there might be augmented or there might
be a different layer of technology used
and that's really exciting for me the
biggest uses will be VR within those
kinds of immersive experiences theater
art galleries shared experiences and
then more use will be with augmented
reality because it's easy it's on our
phones you know we can engage with
different things on our phones we will
eventually have Holograms in our eyes we
can project whatever we want on the wall
we could be watching the same television
we're watching two different programs
just see whatever our lenses work we'll
program today
but that's what I think will happen like
I think that's where we will go and
that's much more likely to happen and
people sticking headsets on because it's
too intrusive yeah and they're still
heavy and it ruins your hair and it
leaves marks around your face yeah it
might annoy look look like after 48
hours we were swapping with lots of
different headsets really using the gay
VR headsets is in the day when some
swing was still great in VR and we're
using the referees and the vibe we're
using the PlayStation that just come out
so so yeah we had lots of different head
sucks yeah at the very start you
mentioned Holograms for me a hologram is
the security seal on the back of my
driving license and that thing that
brought Michael Jackson back to life
that one time there was meant to be an
Amy Winehouse hologram tour and you know
the technology that's being used for
holograms is really interesting and a
little creepy
maybe so so it works well in a number
different ways so they can use old
footage and they can also recreate and
get mannerisms right some use like big
green screens and motion capture others
are using loads of notes digital images
from past footage and putting them all
together and then it's just projections
it's like a normal hologram the you do
with a CD case of projecting lights in
and creating things you might you might
do if you're nerdy at home I'm sure
everybody does so yes it said that
that's you know I'd say it's really
really simple
it's obviously not it's hugely technical
and costs a fortune but I think with
with
technology from hololens and obviously
Microsoft have been working on you can
really start to think how might you use
Holograms as a storytelling technique
interacting in different ways and and
there was a really interesting
experience which I cannot remember the
name of it I can see the poster boy is a
Sheffield doc fest around two years ago
I will let you know because it is really
really interesting where it was an
immigration officer and you were you had
to decide whether to let people into the
country or not based on their stories so
you were grilling them and it was all on
the hololens so more been augmented
reality you can see through with the
glasses and it's projecting in front of
you so it's not a VR headset okay you're
not watching something you're seeing the
real world and then is it overlaying
what's the difference between it and
it's very very similar technology so so
yeah the hololens well the hologram is
simply the way that it's projected so
you understood the light beams coming
down on there and projecting on there
where with AR it's more that's digital
representation but they were using the
hololens to have these characters you
had to interview to decide whether they
would get into the country or not and
determine and determine by your language
you are choosing to use and the
decisions you made the Holograms would
get more real they get more vibrant or
they would be slowly withering away and
I thought that was really interesting
where it's very early days 40 years ago
a Sheffield but it was a really
interesting way of how you might use our
technology to interact with things so I
do think with augmented reality and with
Holograms you can start start seeing
things a little bit differently how much
you know and what might be interesting
the other day I started watching the new
Blade Runner which is just
got up on Netflix and in that Ryan
Gosling yeah he's one of the Ryan's
right someone has got it's not Ryan
Reynolds
sorry it's Ryan Gosling he's got a fake
girlfriend that supplied to him by this
company and she's walking through and
we've seen this in films million times
right that is that is that going to be
possible to be able to have that to be
able to project something 3d into the
air which is broadly opaque as well and
is able to move through because
obviously the hologram at the moment I
didn't quite know that it was still
essentially just that CD case projector
type thing yeah yeah you can't have this
big backdrop moving around or else it's
gonna start cluttering idiots tables and
chairs when it's supposed to be sitting
down yeah is there anything on the
horizon that allows us to do anything
like that I'm sure there's lots of
people working on that and and certainly
when you're you're looking at kind of
lenses in your eyes and you know
different glasses you might be wearing
which is what Halloween microsoft
hololens is and magic leap and all of
those that's what they're working on I'm
always hugely top-secret but you know
that that kind of technology is allowing
that I mean simply if you look at yeah
I've seen the real kind of crass basic
version when you've got Pokemon go and
you're playing with the little little
things around and they're in the house
and they might be might be in your room
you've got them obviously through the
lens of your phone but if that's being
projected in different ways you can see
you can see that but then it is it any
different then - you know cyber
relationships in the 80s or the 90s and
it's just a case of scaling that
technology either up or down however you
want to look at it so that you've got it
always-on potentially in your eyes
potentially you're always overlaid over
the top of things
you are right I guess yeah I guess that
what we're talking about with this
hologram the later on a hologram versus
Pokemon go
is simply a case of convenience is it in
your eyes is it always on do you
actually have this sense that you're
doing something or is it just a part of
your day-to-day life well as Google
glass pinned discontinued just focus
yeah I I was a glass whole I would yeah
I was one of those I've got lots of
faces of me you know with my glass
ongoing working out the weather yeah and
I kind of felt really sad for because I
thought the ambition is there the
technology isn't ok so what would the
stomach first of all you look like a
glass hole it it wasn't very comfortable
yeah but for me I felt like you know
it's quite a narrow glass and you had to
look up constantly to see what was being
projected so if you had like your normal
glass you were looking up here all the
time and that's really quite
uncomfortable kind of look really
gormless cuz I'm looking up all the time
but the intention was there and you know
what sucha have done with their snapchat
glasses and filming from the glasses all
the time and being able to you know
broadcast whatever is he or seeing at
any time that was quite similar to what
glass were doing so if you went into you
to filming made with glass it would be
filming you cycling on your way to work
which is just what what snapchats done
with their lenses so there's quite a few
people kind of experimenting with you
know what is it like but there is still
the huge kind of privacy issues that
concern around you know what are you
capturing all the time you know that's
really hard and it's really hard to
navigate that that there aren't that
there aren't enough kind of laws or
regulations in place to be able to
govern all of that on to any of those
concerns
and that's a massive question we're
saying we're people would naturally have
a inclination against that but probably
50% of people got a smart speaker in the
home now yeah exactly
well that's a league last with or 2012
say maybe it would be different I'm not
sure I think it's something yeah it's
interesting the fact it's to do with the
visual so in James clears Bach atomic
habit C gives us great fact that he says
in the human body there's about 14
million cells that are dedicated to
sense and 11 million of them are
dedicated to sight that's how highly we
discriminate our sight over other other
senses yeah and there was a someone will
be able to tell me what this is there
was a YouTube video that I watched not
long ago where it was trying to show
people how uncomfortable they felt when
they realized they were under
surveillance and this person went in and
sat down straight in front of a couple
at a restaurant and just had the camera
like that and just didn't say anything
and people stayed freaking out started
losing their [ __ ] I would sit down next
to someone who was reading the paper a
park bench and just put the camera in
the face and yeah the the difference is
that it was a camera across the street
it's a camera in the corner of the shop
it's camera whatever whatever but
there's something very very invasive
this that creepy and visceral and just
weird about knowing that someone's
watching in a way that knowing that
someone's listening isn't and even in
the way that knowing that someone's
watching statically isn't as well I
think I yeah there's some big hurdles
for that sort of technology to overcome
yeah yeah and I think I mean we give
ourselves away so freely online
constantly but there is still that we're
just a little bit uneasy with and I
think that goes back to that problem of
you know accessibility with VR that it
still is too close it's intrusive it's
on
head is uncomfortable so you have all of
that kind of playing out constantly but
yeah I mean I I do think the the light
of the technology gets the easier gets
to use I used to have like a clip on VR
lens that would be clipped onto my phone
so I could watch VR content through like
a clip-on double lens okay yes it's a
you'd have your phone and these lenses
would adapt onto it to make it into a vr
viewer so I've got my little VR view
wherever I am I don't see with you know
cardboard headsets and all those kinds
of things whole collection of headsets
through history it's really fun yeah
it's it's quite interesting to see that
those changes and as we get lighter and
I say get more comfortable and easier
but still I'm just not sure if lots of
people are gonna stick on a headset it's
not as if iPhone was the first
touchscreen phone it's the first one
it's the first one that was able to
deliver the technology sufficiently
seamlessly for people to adopt it yeah
and it's the same with this what's the
company what's the company that he's
going to get first move right right
example they didn't have a phone until
they did that they've been loads of
people who'd been in the phone space you
had doubled with touchscreen phone then
blackberry and had one that was like
touch on keypad and blah blah blah but
you know so it might very well might be
and it could be Apple Apple could come
out with some who we are and just
totally storm the market which which is
Wow
it's funny and it's good it good that
capitalism allows the best product to
rise to the top it always makes me feel
sad for like goop or Google glass like
2012 slaving away just when you try to
make it work and then there's Apple 15
years later coming in with our Apple
eyes or whatever they call and they yeah
yeah I see I do for us and I love the
fact that they tried really hard and it
could have been great and they thought
the intention was completely
right and I don't think Apple are gonna
do much with fear I think that they are
really buying into the a are marking I
think whatever they bring out you know
you've got the AR kit on Apple there's
lots of great things like reality
composure where you can it's all open
source you can bring in kind of digital
objects and download their app to kind
of project those objects in your
environment so you know there's great
examples that some teachers are using
getting kids engaged with stuff and
looking at kind of roadmaps and kind of
the solar system and holding planets in
your hands and looking around there and
that kind of technology is brilliant and
that's all being done through AR through
AR care and things like reality composer
that kids are using on their iPads and
really really engaging with so I think
that's where Apple will be and whether
they come out with glasses or whatever
it might be there's always lots of
Reimers a lot of leaks but you know we
will see it was if it was Apple they'd
be able to trademark that I I I'm not
sure I could like I I yeah I mean it's
quite funny they're they came out with
the watch and it was very much it's not
called the eye watch it's the watch and
yes it maybe it will just be I really
serious everything else was I some
Harris talked about a while ago and I'm
gonna butcher it but you'll be you'll
know what I'm talking about
Sam's concern was as technology allows
us to become more immersive that been
some very that been some studies done
which showed a R and V R's ability to
change people's political views their
views towards I think
climate change a tree felling there was
something as well you know I'm talking
about or am I just okay can you tell the
listeners why I'm on about cos yeah I
mean there been loads of conversations
and discussions and lots of things
around this so we basically say that VR
as an immersive media has the capacity
the potential to change perceptions to
change understanding so enough that's
why we like it so you know if you want
to experience yet clouds over Sidra an
incredible piece done by Chris milk a
few years ago one of the big kind of VR
360 kind of experiences following the
journey of a girl in a refugee camp in
Jordan so that's was designed to drive
empathy it was meant to invoke that
sense of we need to take action you know
it was designed to be shown to
decision-makers of the UN to get them to
understand more and change their minds
and get them to do more so the
technology has been used for all of that
it's been labeled as this empathy
machine which i think is a load of
nonsense but that's what it's been
labeled as if you take that argument
there it can change minds you can put
the technology in other people's hands I
guess and to change minds in different
ways if the technology has that power to
change what you're thinking about
something where does it go with
subliminal messaging where does it go
with arguing for something else
there's been really really interesting
studies around gender swapping in VR
getting people to experience different
genders and then seeing how that changes
attitudes and behavior in the workplace
now feel what it's like for a woman to
be the only woman in a board room full
of men
those kinds of scenarios some of them
are really powerful so some of them have
been shown to have impact there was one
around at the Stanford virtual human
interaction lab where they did something
around homelessness and they had two
groups and one group just received
information on flat screens and
brochures and that kind of stuff and the
other one experienced it the other group
was experiencing homelessness in
immersive experiences and connecting
with people and then they repeated it
and then they they looked at the data
over who was who was still more
empathetic who who was actually who had
changed their behavior and all of the
studies showed that it was the group
that were exposed to it in an immersive
way because they had that close
relationship so so yeah you are looking
at a technology that can potentially
change people's minds if that is for the
wrong way how is that monitored how is
that regulated we're talking pretty much
inquirer unregulated industry so yeah I
think that the concept of brain hacking
and changing the mind to think changing
the brain and the way they are thinking
in your beliefs and your motivations is
really interesting but a little bit
freaky yeah was the only thing that I
the analogy that can kind of draw here
is that with social media it's we had no
idea that it was going to come social
media was a change the fact that you
have a screen in your pocket which is
able to layer all sorts of different
mental models and cognitive biases on
top of itself like an echo chamber and
confirmation bias and you know all the
different things that you have when you
follow people on Twitter and then the
algorithm starts to redeliver you more
content which you know either outrage or
agreement of the two things etc etc all
that stuff right so you you we we didn't
know what was going to go on with that
that happened and now I think everyone
has realized we
Blee [ __ ] up a bit with social media
we've probably uncovered or there's not
enough governance around are these
things a platform or a pipeline are
there publisher should we be monitoring
the content should they be allowed to
deep platform people if they're not
breaking the law all this sort stuff and
I think a lot of the general public and
sort of techie people looking forward
now with a little bit more mindfulness
about what what's going on are we are we
about to unleash the next thing and then
the analogy some Harris uses it's really
really interesting is he talks about how
he sees a ceiling there's a ceiling on
how much behavior change you can get
from a two dimensional phone that's in
your hand and that that ceiling gets
raised and we don't know by how much how
much does he get raised by AR how would
she get raised by VR how much should get
raised by I guess this always on VR
holographic sort of stuff which went
between AR VR and and and something else
yeah again you know before the Manhattan
Project that you didn't need to have any
legislation for nuclear bombs because
there's no nuclear bombs and inevitably
with technology the legislation always
lags behind the actual technology coming
out you can and on top of that once the
genies out of the bottle it's not going
back in the cage yeah so it's really
yeah it's a glad I'm not having to
legislate or govern in it sounds like it
would be a bit messy I mean there was
the the government did a select
committee looking at immersive
technologies and addiction which starts
in January so I gave evidence to it in
January which is all a little bit
surreal
Thomas yeah yes the DCMS and the report
was published I knew a few weeks ago
September the 12th I think this is all
online and and that's really interesting
actually it's really interesting
findings in there and it's gaming and
addiction but also around immersive as
well and one thing there I spoke a lot
about was you know the impact and
everything that we've learned from
bullying and social networks that need
to be stopped before it starts and it's
already starting in VR social spaces and
there was a really interesting study
done last year with loads of people that
were using social vr spaces and the
amount of people is like sixty percent
of people felt that they've been
harassed in social spaces in VR
particularly women but quite a high
number of men as well and I've always
found social vr really creepy like I
don't like here it always reminds me of
that kind of early internet chat room
where it's like in social BR when these
weird kind of bodyless of this or
legless kind of avatars come creeping up
to you and be like hey think about the
people who have adopted that technology
at this stage of its life way to make
your guests feel something and we don't
know what it's selecting for be
selecting for the first PhD in immersive
storytelling but we know there's a you
know there's gonna be some people in
there who are non-typical by virtue of
the fact that there's not many of yeah
yeah absolutely and there are some great
things being done and so she'll be our
spaces and there's quite a lot now of
kind of women-only rooms but you can all
say you know gates campfires you can go
and like musical nights you can do
karaoke on a Friday night it's very much
the Oasis ready player one it's very
much that kind of world you've got lots
of different places to explore but what
the tech companies have done which is
really good if you are in a social space
and people are coming towards you and
it's freaking you out you can put a
safety bubble around you so you you
create this kind of this is my personal
space you get out of my bubble kind of
restriction
I run nightclubs that's my job every
nightclub for 13 years and if I can get
someone to create a real-life version my
work life next in terms of its comfort
get out of my personal space
I need a roundabout three feet in all
directions please think absolutely
absolutely again it shows the fact that
we have this very visceral response to
two people and we can't we can't
distinct because there's nothing to be
afraid of like it's just another chat
room you don't know if my bits are close
to your like bit in the way that we're
transferring information now but because
it's not represented visually in a way
that our senses can tell another
bothered so it comes down to that
question of how real is the virtual
really and do we perceive it to be real
or not and if what we're trying to get
to is a place where we cannot decipher
what's real and what's not then that can
be you know it can be just as bad you
know if it's for somebody to you know
harass you virtually whether it's within
a virtual reality environment or whether
it's on a cyber bullying thing it's
still harassment so it it's quite
difficult to kind of comprehend and it's
difficult for people to accept that it's
just as bad so there it is well anyone
who knows about the rubber hand
experiment yeah no play knows that you
can literally trick your brain by using
visual cues into you're feeling
something physically yeah and forget how
it feels emotionally yeah it really is
bit of minefield isn't it yeah mmm you
can always press your bubble
I want it for the real world so dr.
Jones today's been amazing thank you so
much you very much for having me if the
listeners want to find out some more
things is there any cool blogs or
websites or where would you direct them
and why can they why can they find you
as well yeah I said I I'm on Twitter
live on Twitter virtual so DJ always
online or in a virtual world somewhere
but there are loads of really like all
of the tech platforms upload VR all of
those kinds of places are great for kind
of immersive news and just try and check
out so I'd always say you could try and
check out we've just had rain dance the
last weekend which has been full of
really interesting VR experiences and if
anyone is in Bristol there's the first
VR cinema based in Bristol run by
Catherine Allen I'm called lemon it's
lemony I can't say that word find it
Bristol's VR which is is great and they
have loads of great experiences on so
it's a really easy way to get important
so really good stuff there - awesome dr.
Jones thank you so much for your time
thanks to everything we've spoken about
will be in the show notes below virtual
Sarah J on Twitter if you have any
questions feel free to go and drop her a
message for now thank you very much
[Music]